from city streets in Los Angeles two
full forests on a distant planet more
environments are being digitally created
instead of shot in camera the artists
who sculpt model and render these
environments need powerful tools to
efficiently build the world in the
director's vision now you could create
trees individually using traditional
modeling techniques which is
time-consuming but what happens or what
happens when you want to generate
multiple plants or trees to create an
entire landscape SpeedTree cinema is
commercial software which is initially
designed to create a virtual golf course
for video games but shifted direction
with the realization that it could be
used for film since then it has grown to
become a motion picture visual effects
tool grown get it has trees come on
people drums right thank you okay so
speed tree enables the rapid precision
modeling of a virtually unlimited
variety of convincing trees and
vegetation by combining an easy building
process and direct manipulation first
used in a little indie film called
avatar
the software has made a huge impact in
the industry and is featured in some of
the biggest movies that require digital
trees and farce for their design
engineering and implementation of
SpeedTree cinema the Academy presents a
technical achievement award to Michel
Sechrist seacrest Chris King and Greg
Croft
first we'd like to thank the Academy for
this great honor and the entire
SpeedTree team particularly to Kevin
Meredith who's been with us since the
beginning
Steve Clipper wits Sonia pious etske and
Richard Robinson we'd like to thank IOM
and Richard bluff for taking a huge
chance on us with avatar and we like to
thank USC that's Gamecocks not Trojans
especially professors Robert Pettis and
Roger Dougal and a big thanks to our
users who does a great job of making our
small part looks so good on the big
screen personally when I was 10 years
old my parents bought me a computer and
a programming manual instead of the next
game console so thanks to my parents Jim
and Carol for getting me started
fast forward 20 years to this photograph
this is one of the first leaf map since
Petrie and that's my wife's hand holding
a piece of foam inside of a bush and
it's a it's a very tiny tiny example of
the tremendous support that she and my
family have provided me so thanks to my
wonderful kids Claire Conner Harrison
and especially my beautiful wife Melissa
thanks for everything
my mother would like to thank the
Academy for awarding her son something
that she can finally brag about video
games just aren't as interesting to her
I would like to thank my parents for
their tremendous support Angela and Sam
as well as my brother Lindsey I'd like
to thank my children James and Catherine
for their tremendous understanding about
the many many late nights and finally to
my wife Lisa my high school sweetheart
with whom I've been on such a journey I
could have done it without you doll and
I love you thank you our professional
thanks have been covered so just on a
personal note I'd like to thank my
beautiful and very pregnant wife Audrey
my daughter Nora my parents Russ and Pam
Croft my family friends and just
basically everyone who has helped guide
me through life thank you